part of it is probably surely better
prudential regulation of individual
institutions and as one looks at the
stories of what has happened in some
cases the choices that individual
institutions made are sort of stunning
this almost stunning in their
insensitivity to risk and one wonders
whether that shouldn't or couldn't have
been monitored and watched more more
closely but i think the deeper
imperative and the imperative that has
less fully run through our thinking
about financial regulation is what i
would call regulation for systemic
stability that recognizes that our all
what we ultimately care about in this is
not the shareholders and the employees
of one particular financial institution
but what we ultimately care about is
what's going to happen to the big real
economy the stuff that's captured in my
high unemployment rate and in bobst
trillions of dollars of losses and
thinking about systemic stability here
are some examples of the things you
think about if you're focused on that
what kind of clearing house are we going
to have so that problems in one
institution don't become problems
throughout the system are we get we've
learned something important that
clearing has an old Clearinghouse
example might be something Stock
Exchange is not an example but if you
look at me but as a regular part it
would have worked less well over would
have worked less well over time if you
traded stock with one other person and
you just have to rely on that one person
being credit worthy and delivering the
stock clearing houses are one example
second example which involves a variety
of sort of legal and technical issues is
making the system safe for failure
lehman brothers wasn't the biggest
financial institution in the country it
wasn't one of the five biggest financial
institutions in the country and yet its
failure has been followed by cataclysmic
consequences couldn't we can't we find a
way to enable an institution to fail and
the various interconnections be
contained in such a way that that
failure doesn't have the kind of
systemic consequences that we've seen
that's important for the system it's
also important for the institutions to
be part of finding that because if we
can't find such things and we have a
system that's completely unable to
handle failure that's going to be a
system where we're going to have to take
risk down an enormous extent and that
will in turn have a set of consequences
for the dynamism of our economy
you